[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
EMILY MATLACK:
Thank you, Carlos.
We really appreciate it.
And thank you all for
being here with us today.
I am Emily.
JASE LINDGREN: I'm Jase.
DEDEKER WINSTON: I'm Dedeker.
EMILY MATLACK: And
as you said, we
are the hosts of the
Multiamory Podcast, which
is a weekly podcast that we've
been doing for about four years
now.
Today, we're here to talk
to you about the thing
that our podcast
continually comes back to,
and that is non-monogamy and
nontraditional relationships.
Since we've started
the podcast, we've
encountered every type of
question, of misunderstanding,
of stigma, that you could
possibly think about
and that you could possibly
think that would probably
come to people like us.
And really, that's
one of the reasons why
we started this podcast,
just because there are so
many misconceptions about what
polyamory and non-monogamy even
is.
DEDEKER WINSTON: So the
name of this talk today is
"Non-Monogamy for Non-Majors,"
which is a little bit weird.
But we'll explain why.
So my main form
of work is I work
as a certified
relationship coach.
I specialize in
working with people
who are connected to
non-monogamy in some way,
whether it's people who are
trying to discover if it's
right for them, if
it's a couple who
are trying to open
up their relationship
for the first time.
I work with people
kind of in a counseling
therapeutic capacity.
And so when I talk to
people about my work
or about my personal
life, I get a wide variety
of reactions, sometimes good,
sometimes bad, and sometimes
just really weird.
There was one time that I was
working with this photographer
on an unrelated job.
And this was two
or three years ago.
I was in the middle of writing
the manuscript for my book.
And he starts asking
about the book,
and so I start describing
what it's about, polyamory,
and nontraditional sexuality,
and things like that.
All of a sudden, he cuts me off.
And he goes, oh,
I can't hear this.
I can't hear this-- la, la,
la, la, la, la, la, la, la.
And so of course, I'm
like, well, that was weird.
And I asked him, like, why--
why can't you hear about this?
And I'll never forget
what he said to me.
He said, if I learn about
this, I can never unlearn it.
And that really struck me
because I was like, wow.
I realized he is
afraid that just
by hearing about the
concepts, somehow it's
going to get on him, and maybe
he's going to be converted
or something.
It's like the non-monogamy toxic
waste is going to get on him
and turn him into this
radioactive monster.
And that sounds like a really
weird reaction, and it is.
But it's actually become
surprisingly common
for all three of us, whenever we
talk about the work that we do,
that people feel like by having
any contact with the subject
whatsoever, they're going to
turn into radioactive monsters
somehow.
JASE LINDGREN: So
today, our talk,
"Non-Monogamy for the
Non-Major," or non-monster,
if you will, is because we're
here just to educate about what
this is, what it actually
looks like in real life--
not to proselytize to you, not
to tell you that any one way
of doing relationships is
better than any other way,
but simply to dispel
some of the myths.
And in doing that,
our hope is to make
this company, this community,
and our world a safer place
for all sorts of people.
Also, so we're going
to spend about half
the time doing a
presentation about that.
And then other half
is for questions.
We've had some that have
been submitted already
through the dory for this event.
You can also feel free to
furiously do those right now,
if you want to remain anonymous
in asking your questions.
And then there's also
the microphone over here
for asking those later as well.
EMILY MATLACK: Yeah, but
before we do any of that,
we want to get into the why.
Why talk about
non-monogamy at all?
JASE LINDGREN: So when
we started this podcast
four years ago, my best friend
was talking to me about it.
And he was like,
so I don't get it.
Why do you need to
talk about stuff
that happens in the bedroom?
Can't you just keep that in the
bedroom like everybody else?
And it's essentially like asking
someone wearing a wedding ring,
really, do you have to flaunt
your sex in front of all of us?
Can't you just keep that in
the bedroom where it belongs?
EMILY MATLACK: And
really, the truth
is that all of these
relationship styles
really run the gamut from
casual to lifelong commitments.
And they are an integral
part of many people's lives,
just like anyone's
significant other
is a really vital part
of someone's life.
And it is important to
talk about non-monogamy
because it is prevalent.
DEDEKER WINSTON: Yeah, it's
surprisingly prevalent.
So there was a study in 2016 in
the "Journal of Sex and Marital
Therapy" that found that within
the US, 20% of the population
has been involved in
some kind of consensually
open relationship at
some point in their life.
And the study defined a
consensually open relationship
as any relationship
where both partners
agree that they're
allowed to have
sexual or romantic
relationships outside
of that primary relationship.
20% boils down to about
one in five people,
which is quite a lot.
JASE LINDGREN: And another study
in the "Journal of Psychology
and Sexuality" suggests that
between 4% and 5% of Americans
are currently in some kind of
non-monogamous relationship.
So that's about 16 million
people, just in the US.
EMILY MATLACK: And just to
put that in perspective--
because that doesn't sound
like, maybe, that many people--
but 6% of the American
population is vegan.
I'm vegan.
Thank you Google for
giving me vegan food today.
I really appreciate it.
I'm also polyamorous,
so I'm extra special.
But probably most
of you know someone
who identifies as vegan.
And it doesn't really
seem that rare, does it?
DEDEKER WINSTON: So the thing
is that in the work that we do,
we've come across people
in all lines of work,
from all walks of life, who
identify as non-monogamous.
The people who
are non-monogamous
and polyamorous-- it's not just
your burlesque dancer cousin
who goes to Burning
Man every year.
It's everyone.
It's your Uber driver.
It's your kid's teacher.
It's your therapist.
It's your lawyer.
It's your doctor.
It's all kinds, all walks
of life, like I said.
Maybe the person
sitting next to you.
Again, 20%, even
5%, that's still
a huge chunk of the population.
JASE LINDGREN: And
yet, despite the fact
that this is so prevalent,
there is a fundamental lack
of education and awareness about
non-monogamy, which as we've
seen with other sorts of fringe
groups or marginalized groups,
that this leads to fear.
EMILY MATLACK: And there are
a lot of different reasons
why someone might be
fearful of non-monogamy.
For example, a person who is
quite happy being monogamous,
they may learn about
monogamy, or may
be worried that their partner
will learn about non-monogamy,
and then suddenly want to change
their relationship structure.
Or like the photographer
that Dedeker talked about,
if they themselves learn about
non-monogamy, all of a sudden,
maybe, they're going to want
to become non-monogamous
themselves.
JASE LINDGREN: For other people,
it brings up unresolved issues
around infidelity in the past.
Maybe it brings up hurtful
memories of being cheated on
or guilt of having
cheated on somebody else.
DEDEKER WINSTON: And the other
part of this fearful response
is often, it's just a
product of growing up
in an extremely
sex-negative culture,
like American culture is.
And it's this ingrained sex
negativity that teaches us
that any kind of
sex, or any kind
of romance, that doesn't
happen within the context
of a heterosexual
marriage that's
for the purpose of procreation--
we treat all that
kind of sex that
falls outside of that
bubble as being wrong,
as being dangerous,
as being dirty,
as being something that
we should be afraid of
and that we should
shun and try to avoid.
So the thing is that this fear
leads to a whole cornucopia
of misunderstandings.
JASE LINDGREN: Yes.
So when people talk about their
non-monogamous relationships,
they come up against all
sorts of misunderstandings
and misconceptions
about what it is.
And they can range
from the somewhat
aggressive, like, oh--
or accusatory-- of oh,
does that mean
you're a sex addict?
Or isn't this just a
different form of cheating?
Or to even seemingly
good natured pitying of,
oh, that's awful.
Is your husband
making you do that?
Or well, I hope someday you find
someone who actually loves you.
DEDEKER WINSTON: It's rough.
JASE LINDGREN: And this
fear and misunderstanding
combined with each other
is what creates stigma.
DEDEKER WINSTON: So there
was a study performed
at the University of
Michigan specifically
on trying to figure
out how stigma affects
non-monogamous
relationships, or people
in non-monogamous relationships.
And so the interesting thing
is they found in this study
that generally,
non-monogamous and polyamorous
relationships are
perceived negatively
by the general population.
But it's not just
that they're perceived
to be less moral, or less
ethical, or less committed,
or less romantic, this
negative perception bled
into other completely
arbitrary areas of life.
EMILY MATLACK:
Yeah, for example,
the participants in
the study thought
that people who
were non-monogamous
were less likely to take a
daily multi-vitamin than people
who are monogamous.
DEDEKER WINSTON: It's true.
JASE LINDGREN: They
also thought they
were less likely to floss
their teeth every day,
walk their dog every day, or
get their taxes filed on time.
DEDEKER WINSTON: Yeah.
And so that sounds
ridiculous, right?
But the thing is that
perception still has an impact.
Because the thing is that the
fear, the misunderstanding,
the stigma--
these things all compound.
They add on top of each other.
And they add up to real
world consequences.
So it's funny to
think about the fact
that you might
perceive someone's
less likely to take
a multi-vitamin,
or less likely to
walk their dog,
or floss their
teeth-- that's funny.
But if we're living
in a world where
stigma towards
non-traditional relationships
is so deeply ingrained that
we think that it affects
whether or not someone can
get their taxes done on time,
how comfortable
is your accountant
going to be to talk about
her own non-monogamous
relationship?
These things result
in actual impact.
JASE LINDGREN: And
it's not only that,
but this bleeds over into other
things such as child custody.
This is something that
tends to come up a lot.
There's not a lot of
formal statistics on it
because most of these cases
are settled out of court.
But non-monogamy, or polyamory,
can be used against people
in custody battles,
often by family members,
like their own parents trying to
take their kids away from them,
and that judges,
without this knowledge,
and having that stigma
in their heads of well,
they're less likely
to walk their dogs,
they have no moral fabric--
yeah, they're probably
not a good person
to raise a child either.
EMILY MATLACK: And there's also
zero workplace protections.
If your boss finds out
you're non-monogamous,
there's no legal ramifications
for them firing you.
And also, it's very
difficult for us
to access things like
poly-friendly counseling,
poly-friendly therapists,
legal services.
And it also makes it
more difficult for things
like adoption or
parenting rights.
DEDEKER WINSTON: Yeah,
especially in those child
custody cases,
finding a lawyer who
understands the situation
of the parents, who
maybe is an open marriage.
On the coast, like
maybe in California--
a little bit easier.
But not so much in the
middle of the country.
And the thing is
that, of course,
with all of these real
world consequences,
these get amplified, depending
on intersection of identity.
So for instance, someone
who is married or unmarried,
someone who's
uneducated, someone
who is poor, someone who
is a person of color,
who is already dealing with
real world consequences
from stigma, adding
these on top of it
just adds more to that
complexity and that difficulty.
JASE LINDGREN: So
now we're going
to move on to talk about
some myths versus reality.
DEDEKER WINSTON: So that's the
thing is that toxic combination
that we saw-- the fear,
plus the misunderstanding,
plus the stigma--
we've already seen how that
toxic combination affects
other marginalized communities.
We've seen how that affects
the trans community,
the gay community,
immigrants, things like that.
And so what we
found, the best way
to combat that toxic
cocktail, as it were,
is through awareness, through
education, through information.
So before we dive
into specific actions
that we can all take to help
combat some of these things
and help make our
environment safer for people
in nontraditional
relationships, we're
going to try to tackle the
most common misconceptions.
That's where we're tackling
some myths versus reality.
JASE LINDGREN: So the first
one is that it's all about sex.
Like I said, the
question of oh, does
that mean you're a sex addict?
Or well, it's unsafe.
You're going to have sex in
front of children or something.
That's why we need to
take them away from you.
The why talk about this,
if it's just something
that happens in the bedroom?
And this has become also so
prevalent because of the way
the media likes to talk about
it because it excites us.
We see this picture.
This is the iconic picture
of a polyamorous, or open,
relationship.
It seems to imply that
we're all naked, or at least
bare-footed in bed all the time.
[LAUGHTER]
DEDEKER WINSTON: But
seriously, every single article
about non-monogamy, you'll
find that stock image.
It's always the feet.
JASE LINDGREN: Yeah.
EMILY MATLACK: But
in reality, there's
actually a variety
of motivations
why someone would want to be in
a non-monogamous relationship.
And obviously, there's
no doubt that sex
can be a really important
part of a relationship.
But honestly, just any
type of romance, sex
may or may not be included
in that relationship.
And there are many
asexual people
who identify as
polyamorous, and sex may not
be a part of the
equation for them at all.
And also, just like
monogamous people,
individual preferences
and amount of sex
can vary from person to
person and relationship
to relationship.
DEDEKER WINSTON:
So the next myth
that we're going to
tackle is the myth
that non-monogamous
relationships are unethical,
or that they are coercive.
So we do need to tackle
the question of ethics.
Because what often happens
is we get questions like,
well, isn't that just
cheating on your partner?
Aren't you just giving your
partner a hall pass to cheat on
you?
And it makes sense why
the comparison gets drawn,
because I think in
our media for so long,
our only model of
non-monogamy that we've
seen for a long time
has been cheating,
or non-consensual, or
non ethical non-monogamy.
And so it makes sense that
we draw that parallel.
However, it's important to
bear in mind that cheating
is based in dishonesty.
It's based in
lying to a partner.
And so that means
that even people
who are polyamorous,
or non-monogamous,
can still cheat
on their partner,
if they lie about it,
if they omit something,
if they cover it up.
I don't know why people do it.
It's part of why I have a job.
And then about the
coercive part--
there's often this assumption
that surely, one person must be
forcing the other to do this.
And usually, the assumption
is that the man--
if it's a heterosexual
relationship,
the assumption is that the
man must be forcing the woman
to do this.
Because no woman would
want this, and every man
must want this.
JASE LINDGREN: Right.
And in reality, polyamorous
and non-monogamous people
have ethical codes
just like anybody else.
In fact, sometimes are
even more conscious
about creating those
ethical codes--
things like not being
competitive in a negative way,
intentionally
fostering compassion
for each other, and then
honest communication, which
is a huge part of polyamory.
If you ever read
any books or listen
to any podcasts on the
subject, honest communication
is a topic that comes
up over and over again.
And in the same
way that you don't
need a religious upbringing
to have morals and ethics,
you also don't need to have
a monogamous relationship
to treat that ethically as well.
And then the subject of
coercion-- this one is actually
interesting, so it
surprises a lot of people--
and that's that statistically,
in heterosexual couples,
women are actually more likely
to be the ones who suggest
an open relationship, or a
non-monogamous relationship,
than men are.
EMILY MATLACK: So
for our next myth,
we are going to tackle
the thought that everybody
is in a group relationship,
or in a triad.
So the media has this
very typical image
of what a polyamorous
relationship looks like.
And honestly, you've
probably all seen it before.
It's this idea that there is
a white male, female, female
triad.
The media likes to call
it a thruple, which
is not a real word.
We don't actually use
that for polyamorous.
But it usually consists of two
bisexual females and a man who
live together, and they make all
of their relationship decisions
together as a unit.
Like this image of
the show "You Me Her."
This is a show that is all
about a polyamorous triad.
But again, it's
like a perfect image
of what the media
likes to perpetuate,
which is, again, this
bisexual female, these two
bisexual females, with a man.
And so this is just
prevalent because the image
is so overused.
It's almost become a
stereotype at this point.
DEDEKER WINSTON: And we
suspect that the reason why
media outlets always try to find
this particular relationship
format of two women and
a man living together
and all in a
relationship together
is if you think about it, it's
kind of the least threatening
version of non-monogamy.
We're already quite
used to seeing the image
of a man with multiple women.
And we're more
comfortable digesting that
than seeing a woman
with multiple men,
on top of the fact
that we're quite used
to seeing bisexual women,
especially for male pleasure,
more so than seeing bisexual
men involved with a woman.
And so it makes sense
why the media always
tries to find this
particular grouping.
But it gives this
incorrect perception
that that's all
that polyamory is,
is that everyone's in this
weird, communal, cult-like
group relationship together.
Because the reality
is that there
is this huge
diversity of formats.
Different motivations and needs
breed very different shapes
in relationships.
People use very
different labels.
Sometimes people call
it an open relationship.
themselves polyamorous,
or relationship
anarchists, which
is a whole other term that we
could do a whole presentation
on.
But unfortunately, not today.
For the most part, in
reality, what we see--
rather than a bunch
of triads, or a bunch
of four-person relationships, or
group relationships-- usually,
we're seeing
interconnecting dyads, so as
in two-person
relationships, where
maybe both people in that dyad
also have another partner,
but those partners are
not related to each other,
and maybe those partners
also have other partners.
So what we see in
real life is usually
these kind of
constellation-esque intimate
networks that sometimes
move, and shift, and change
over time.
And it makes sense
because the same way
with monogamous
relationships, the way
that you create your
relationship is going
to be different, based
on what your context is,
based on if you want
to get married, if you
don't want to get married.
Maybe you don't
want to get married,
but one of your partners
really needs health insurance.
Or if you're choosing
to raise kids together,
or if you're choosing
to not cohabit
with someone who is your life
partner, or multiple life
partners, or things like that.
Ultimately, the takeaway is
that although the media would
have us believe
that it all looks
like this particular shape,
it doesn't all look the same.
JASE LINDGREN: So the
next myth is that it's not
a real relationship.
It's the idea that
oh, well, someday
you'll find someone who
actually loves you enough.
Or oh, I understand
you're young.
Eventually you'll
grow out of this,
and then you'll have
a real relationship.
And I think a lot of this
is because for most people,
casual dating is the closest
analogy that they have.
It's the closest thing
that they understand
that looks sort of like
this, the key difference
being that casual dating
doesn't have commitments
and generally, you're not
ever talking to anyone
you're dating about anyone
else that you're dating.
It's this kind of let's
pretend it's not existing
until we get serious and then
we stop seeing anyone else.
DEDEKER WINSTON:
And the reality is
that actually, people
who are not monogamous
have comparable relationship
satisfaction and experiences
to people who are in
monogamous relationships.
So that same study that
we told you about that
found the stigma about
flossing your teeth
and walking your dog--
that study also found that
there is virtually no difference
in relationship functioning
and relationship
success between people who are
non-monogamous and people who
are monogamous.
They also found that
specifically people who
identified as polyamorous--
as in having multiple romantic
relationships at the same time--
they were found to
experience even higher levels
of satisfaction, of
commitment, of trust,
and of passionate love
in their relationships.
So these myths that we're
talking about today,
and these misconceptions--
obviously, it's not everything.
It's not every
single misconception.
We would be here all night if
we dove into every single one.
But what we want
to move on towards
is talking about the
things that we can all
do to help combat
some of these things,
and again, just to make
the environment safer.
And they're very,
very simple things
that everyone can
do-- very achievable.
JASE LINDGREN: Yeah, go for it.
EMILY MATLACK: Yes.
If you don't practice or
identify with non-monogamy,
then somebody comes
to you and tells you
that they're opening
the relationship up,
the first thing that you
can do is don't freak out.
So if a friend tells you
that they're polyamorous,
they're most likely
not coming on to you.
They're not trying to
steal their husband.
It probably has nothing
to do with you at all.
So don't freak out.
Play it cool, man.
JASE LINDGREN: The next one
is to ask before you assume.
And this means a
number of things.
The first thing is it means
ask before you assume it's
OK to ask a lot of questions.
I know it's weird to ask
a question about asking
questions.
But just because someone
has opened up to you
that they have multiple
romantic relationships
doesn't mean they want to answer
every single detailed question
that you have right now about
it, or at least maybe not right
now at work.
Maybe they want to talk
about that another time.
Let's go out for drinks
sometime and you can ask it.
So just ask before you
launch into those questions.
And then the second
thing is to ask
what are the labels, or the
terms, that they like to use,
so that you can use the correct
ones when talking to them.
For example, if I tell
someone that I'm polyamorous,
and then they say, oh, this
my friend who's polygamous.
I'm like, whoa.
Those are not the same thing.
Please don't use that
word to describe me.
DEDEKER WINSTON: That
happens all the time
that people interchange
those terms.
JASE LINDGREN: Yeah,
but with anything else,
someone might be in
an open relationship
and not want to be
referred to as polyamorous,
or they might prefer
that their partners are
called life partners and not
boyfriends or girlfriends.
Just ask those questions
of, how would you
like me to refer
to this when I'm
talking to you, or about
you with other people?
DEDEKER WINSTON: And the
other important thing to do
is to give acknowledgment.
And that's going to look a
number of different ways.
One way that you can do
this is to just ask someone
about their other partners.
Bear in mind that maybe the
partner that you've always seen
come to work events,
or the partner
that this person lives with
or is raising children with--
it may not be
their only partner.
It may not even be the most
important relationship to them.
So just acknowledging
that this person may
have more than one important
person in their life,
even just by straight
up asking, like, oh,
how's your wife doing?
How's your girlfriend doing?
How's your boyfriend
doing-- things like that.
Most recently when I went
to visit some family out
in Boise, my aunt, who has
been really resistant to this
for a long time--
for the first time
ever, she did this.
She asked, how's Jase doing,
who is one of my partners,
and also asked, how's Alex
doing-- my other partner.
And it was so simple for
her to do, so, so simple.
And it just made me feel so much
more relaxed, and so excited,
and so validated, that
I got to just talk
about the people in my
life that I love to someone
else in my family whom I love.
So again-- super,
super simple thing.
And another trick to this
also, in asking questions--
it's probably best to
avoid asking someone,
well, how many
partners do you have?
It's a very common question.
And the problem is that people
define partners a little bit
differently.
Sometimes it gets a little
bit sticky in the definition.
So it's better just to
ask, who are your partners?
Who's important to you?
Who are the people that
you love in your life,
or who are the people
that are in your life
that you feel like everyone
needs to know about?
Another way that
acknowledgment can look
is by extending an invite.
And this means that if
you're having an event that
has a plus one, maybe consider
offering them a plus two,
so that somebody doesn't have
to choose between which partner
they have to bring.
If, for some reason,
your event's at capacity
and you can't really have
more than a plus one,
let the person that
you're inviting
be the person who decides
who it is that they bring.
It may not be the person
that you're expecting,
and that's OK.
EMILY MATLACK: Don't freak out.
DEDEKER WINSTON:
And don't freak out.
And another way that
acknowledgement can look
is just to take it seriously.
And this can mean things
like don't immediately
tell this person like,
oh, this is just a phase.
You're young.
Oh, you know, you're going to
find your soul mate someday.
It's going to be OK.
Don't offer your pity.
Don't offer to help them
out with walking their dog,
or flossing their teeth,
or doing their taxes.
They're probably going
to be OK with that.
EMILY MATLACK: And lastly,
avoid therapy sessions.
And what we mean by this
is if somebody comes
to you who's non-monogamous
and starts talking
to you about maybe
issues that they
have in their
relationship, don't
try to be their therapist.
Don't tell them like,
oh, well, clearly, it's
your non-monogamy
that's the problem here.
And then on the flip side,
don't make them the therapist.
Don't tell them
about all of the sex
that you've been having
with this other person,
or talking about the
threesome that you
had with your
husband six years ago
and how difficult
it was for you.
Don't make them your therapist.
And also don't be
their therapist.
JASE LINDGREN: So next is if
you do practice non-monogamy,
or you identify
as non-monogamous,
what can you do to help make
this world a safer place?
And the first thing
is to come out.
Now, this one-- a lot
of people go, hleh--
and freaking out about that.
And the thing is that with this,
just like with homosexuality,
the more people come out and
the more people who are willing
and feel safe enough to
speak about it publicly--
if you're privileged to be in
a position where you are safe
to do that with
minimal consequences--
the more people that
do that, the safer it
becomes for everybody.
Because it's been shown in
several studies that simply
knowing someone who is
in a marginalized group,
whether it's gay, whether it's
trans, that simply knowing
someone, or even knowing someone
who personally knows someone,
makes you more likely
to vote favorably
to protect that group.
It makes you less
likely to discriminate
against that group.
DEDEKER WINSTON: So the
other thing that you can do
is you can find support.
Because we all get it.
Any time you're
trying to do something
that goes against the
grain of social norms,
it can be very alienating.
It can be very isolating.
But the thing is that you
don't have to be alone.
You can find support in the
form of meet-up or discussion
groups.
If you Google it, you will find
it, especially here in Seattle.
There's plenty of meet-up
and discussion groups.
I also recommend finding
professional support.
So there is definitely a lack
of therapists, and counselors,
and other professionals
who are friendly
to non-monogamous lifestyles.
But it doesn't mean
they don't exist at all.
Fortunately, the
supply is slowly
starting to catch up to
the demand that's there.
There's a lot of great
resources in directories
for finding this.
There's the Kink Aware
Professionals Directory.
There's the Poly-Friendly
Professionals Directory
for finding people who are
either in your area or willing
to work remotely
with you, who again--
an actual therapy
session, are not
going to immediately go to
your relationship choices
as the source of your
problems, but treat things
a little bit more holistically.
And then another
thing that you can do
is you can find community.
And it doesn't have
to be necessarily
a community that's
based on non-monogamy
or based on a particular
relationship style.
It could be a particularly
supportive work community,
where you feel safe, you
feel like you can be out,
you can talk about what's
going on in your life,
you're not having to do the
mental gymnastics of figuring
out who have I told what,
who has met which partner,
who can never meet this other
partner-- things like that.
EMILY MATLACK: The next
thing that you can do
is be respectful.
And what I mean by that is be
respectful of other people's
relationship structures.
So don't trash monogamy
if you are non-monogamous.
You're not more enlightened
than anyone else is.
We're all just trying
to figure it out.
So be respectful and
be kind to something--
a relationship structure
that's different than yours.
DEDEKER WINSTON: So the
big takeaway here is just
make it safe to be honest.
Make yourself a person who
is safe for other people
to be honest with you.
And it's actually a
relatively simple thing to do.
It just means if
someone opens up
to you about their
relationship, and maybe
that's something that you
would never do in your life
and you have no interest
in whatsoever, that's fine.
You just don't get to
say it to their face.
You can save the big reactions.
And it can also mean speaking
up if you hear someone else
trashing on someone else
for their non-monogamous
relationship.
It's really relatively simple.
And it starts on the individual
level to change a culture,
whether it's a workplace
culture or the culture at large,
of just making it safe
for people to be honest
and to be their true selves.
So right now, we're going
to move into questions.
We have gotten a number of
questions that have been
submitted through the dory.
But before we dive
into that, if there
is anyone who wants to
ask questions on the mic,
we can definitely
go into that now.
JASE LINDGREN: Yeah, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Hi, my name's Garrett.
And I'm curious in hearing
more about the [INAUDIBLE]
societies, especially
in this country.
It seems like our
legal framework
is set up for a relationship
with two people.
In a polyamorous
relationship, how
do you deal with
things like taxes
having only single or married--
and legal things like that?
EMILY MATLACK: Right.
Should I take this one?
JASE LINDGREN: Yeah, go for it.
DEDEKER WINSTON:
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's a really
fascinating conversation.
We've had a number of lawyers
on the podcast, lawyers
who do specialize in family
law for people who are queer,
or polyamorous, or in some kind
of nontraditional sexuality.
And so it is an interesting
time because as opposed to what
we saw with the gay
community, there's
not a ton of people in the
polyamorous, or non-monogamous,
community that
are really pushing
for something like marriage
rights, for instance.
There's not quite this
huge snowballing movement
towards getting marriage rights.
Because it would be
really complicated
to try to figure
out how does it work
signing a legal contract
with multiple people
at the same time.
Do you have overlapping
dyadic legal contracts--
things like that.
What I think, as far as the
legal side of things goes,
is really going to
be the thing that
is the talking point for
non-monogamous relationships--
is more about child custody.
And that's where we're
actually seeing some progress
that there's already been
some precedents set of people
granting parenting rights
to more than two parents,
to three parents.
We've had a couple of
precedents of that.
The other thing is
that there's actually
a lot of people in the
non-monogamous community
that rather than pushing
for marriage rights,
they're pushing
more for increasing
the rights of single
people, so that we
don't have this whole big
bundle of rights that are only
reserved for one particular
relationship type,
but instead making those rights
more accessible to everyone.
So that's kind of
what we're seeing.
As far as specifically
about marriage rights,
I don't think we're going
to see that really take off
any time soon
because of the fact
that again, it's complicated,
and there's not a lot of people
who specifically want marriage.
EMILY MATLACK: But some people
do things like create LLCs--
DEDEKER WINSTON: Yeah.
EMILY MATLACK: Yeah-- in
order to combine assets.
But other than that--
DEDEKER WINSTON:
Especially people
who want to raise a
child together and have
that be protected.
People are making Subchapter
S corporations for years,
creating LLCs for
years-- just kind
of using the legal
tools at their disposal
to protect themselves in
the ways that they want to.
JASE LINDGREN: Because
the truth of the matter
is that marriage
is a legal tool.
We've wrapped it up in this
whole romantic love thing.
But at the end of the
day, it's a contract
that you sign that the state
sanctions and gives you
certain rights, and
responsibilities,
and liabilities that go with it.
So in thinking of it
that way, while there
are many things you can't get
any other way than getting
married, using the corporate
structure in our country
is sort of the next best
thing that we can do.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
JASE LINDGREN:
Thank you so much.
EMILY MATLACK: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Since you see
[INAUDIBLE] maybe 20% of people
who have [INAUDIBLE],,
do you ever find trouble
finding other people
who feel the same way?
EMILY MATLACK: Do we--
JASE LINDGREN: Find
trouble meeting--
EMILY MATLACK: Meeting
other non-monogamous people?
DEDEKER WINSTON: Right, right.
EMILY MATLACK: Yes.
DEDEKER WINSTON: Well, yes.
The thing to bear in mind
is that the internet really
revolutionized that
for a lot of people.
Definitely in the
'90s is when we
started seeing an
actual resurgence
of actual communities
coming together
of people who identified as
polyamorous, or not monogamous,
because people could find
each other for the first time
in a long time.
And so it depends,
based on location.
The West Coast tends
to have pretty robust
non-monogamous communities.
And so people have a relatively
easy-ish time finding partners
to date, or friends,
or communities,
or things like that.
Of course, definitely a
lot harder in the Midwest,
in middle America, for sure.
But there's also a lot of
online communities springing
up as well for people to
connect to each other.
And again, this is
kind of thing is
that like I say, 20% of
the population-- it's huge.
And if we can have--
are there vegan-only
dating sites?
There must be.
EMILY MATLACK: Oh,
yeah, I'm sure.
Definitely.
DEDEKER WINSTON: If we can
have vegan-only dating sites--
EMILY MATLACK: It's a
hard line for some people.
DEDEKER WINSTON: --and vegans
can find each other today,
non-monogamous people can
find each other today as well.
Thank you for your question.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
JASE LINDGREN: And we have
some questions from the dory,
I believe.
AUDIENCE: Yep.
[INAUDIBLE]
So the first one is, what
are your recommendations
for relationships where only
one partner is non-monogamous?
DEDEKER WINSTON: Do
you want to take that?
JASE LINDGREN: Emily, why
don't you take that one?
EMILY MATLACK: This one?
Oh.
JASE LINDGREN: Weren't we just
talking about this before?
EMILY MATLACK: No, I
have the next question.
DEDEKER WINSTON: I can take it.
Yeah, I can take it.
EMILY MATLACK: Go for it.
Go for it.
DEDEKER WINSTON: I can take it.
So I'll reiterate the question--
and we get a version of this
question a lot--
what do you do if one person
in a couple identifies
as non-monogamous or wants to
be non-monogamous and the other
person doesn't?
It's a relatively
common situation
that we see,
especially in couples
who maybe have been
monogamous for a long time
and then one of them realizes,
I think I want to try this,
and this resonates with me.
And the other person says,
I don't know about that.
So these kind of relationships--
sometimes people call them
mono/poly relationships or
some kind of variants of that--
we have seen them
work, for sure.
It requires a lot of compassion,
and a lot of communication,
and a lot of moving slow,
and a lot of negotiation,
and a lot of compromise.
They can work.
The other side of this, the
other prong of this answer,
is reminding people that--
let's say you meet someone.
Maybe you identify
as non-monogamous,
and you meet someone that
you really hit it off with,
you really like them,
but they want monogamy.
If someone's perfect for
you except for the fact
that they want monogamy
and you want non-monogamy,
that person isn't
perfect for you.
That's the other
thing to bear in mind
at the end of the day, which
is not an answer that people
like to hear.
JASE LINDGREN: It's not.
The other thing
I did want to add
about this is that polyamory
and ethical non-monogamy is not
defined by how many people you
personally are dating right
at this moment.
But it's about what you expect
from your partners-- what
are the things that you
expect your partners to be
able to do or to not do.
So my argument for
this, actually,
is in that situation where
one partner is polyamorous
and the other is
monogamous, that actually
the monogamous partner
is the polyamorous one,
if they're OK with having
that relationship where
their partner is able
to see other people.
We have another question?
Yeah.
DEDEKER WINSTON: You're back.
AUDIENCE: I've seen a
couple of documentaries
about non-monogamous
relationships,
and they always take
place in the UK.
So my question is, is the
UK a mecca of non-monogamy?
EMILY MATLACK: We were
thinking about the ones that
took place in San Diego.
AUDIENCE: Or is this
just a documentary thing?
DEDEKER WINSTON: Is the UK
more friendly for these kind
of things, or is it just
a documentary thing--
is that what the question was?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, basically.
JASE LINDGREN: Honestly,
I think this has more
to do with the way that
media gets created here
versus in the UK.
Because we, actually,
just a few months ago,
were talking with
a documentary crew
from the BBC who was
working on something.
And they wanted more
information from us.
And they were even going
to film it in California.
They were trying to decide if
it was going to be California,
or Seattle, or I think
New York, were the places
they were considering.
But still a British
company because of the way
that their public funding
for documentaries and things
like that goes.
I think that might
be part of why.
But I would say, really,
based on what we've seen,
both the coasts here in the
United States and Canada,
as well as the UK, and even
Germany and Scandinavia--
all have very healthy
polyamorous populations.
EMILY MATLACK:
There was a Showtime
show called "Polyamory--
Married and Dating" that was
set in, I guess, San Diego.
So that's interesting.
I didn't even know about
the ones in the UK.
Because that one is the
one that I always think of.
DEDEKER WINSTON:
You do have to bear
in mind that in the
states, we have this--
compared to the
rest of the world--
this very special
cocktail of puritanism
that undercuts everything.
And that still affects the
media that does get produced,
or the stories that do get told.
EMILY MATLACK: Very much.
DEDEKER WINSTON: Although
it is slowly changing.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
DEDEKER WINSTON: Thank you.
JASE LINDGREN: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: What do you
do when your partner is
tired of processing, but you
feel that you're not done yet,
and feel when I'm
satisfied or hurt,
by dropping the conversation?
EMILY MATLACK: So this
is an interesting one
because this happens to me
a lot in my relationships.
I have a partner who is very
good about his boundary of I'm
done talking about this.
And I'm the one who
keeps on wanting
to go, and finish it,
and figure out, OK, I
don't care if we talk all
night, I want to continue
to speak about this.
And we have an acronym that we
use on the show called HALT.
And so it's hungry,
angry, lonely, or tired.
We also added drunk--
HALTD-- onto it.
And if you're any
of those things,
maybe it's not a good
time to do processing
in your relationship, just
simply because you're probably
not up to the best possible
you you can be in that moment.
And I have to halt from time
to time in these relationships
when I do want to
continue talking,
just simply because I know a
little bit of time away from
it-- even if it's 15 minutes--
it can give me a little
bit of understanding
about the situation.
I can step away from it.
And I think that that's
really important to do
in those moments, especially
when you are angry, or upset,
and you're not thinking
clearly, and you're probably
going to say something
that you might regret.
DEDEKER WINSTON: So I
think an important part
of that is making sure that
there's not a dynamic where
the two of you come
together to process,
and there's always
one person who's
shutting down the
conversation, as in, I'm tired,
and this conversation is done.
And that's always what happens.
But that it's a
negotiation, that again,
that you halt, and
you negotiate on when
do we come back to this?
Is it--
EMILY MATLACK: 30
minutes, a day.
DEDEKER WINSTON: Yeah,
do we go take a 30 walk
and then come back to this?
Is this we're going
to schedule this
in our calendar for
this coming Friday
when we'll sit down together
and revisit this again?
EMILY MATLACK: And do you
want to talk about radar?
DEDEKER WINSTON:
Yeah, definitely.
So another way, I think, to
combat burnout on processing
and on talking things through
is to have a regular established
space that's like a relationship
check-in that happens--
we recommend on a monthly basis.
Some people do it
on a weekly basis,
depending on their context.
We created a
framework called Radar
that's actually very loosely
based on Agile Scrum.
It's a long explanation.
EMILY MATLACK: Everybody
in here knows what that is.
DEDEKER WINSTON: We created
this framework called
Radar that's kind of
a process to follow
during this monthly
check-in with your partner
for going through all
these different topics
to check in on, whether
it's sex, or the household,
or talking about other
partners, or things like that,
so that there's this
established time and space
to talk about these
things, to help minimize
day-to-day processing that
can really get you burnt out,
if you know there's going
to be a dedicated time
and space for my
concerns to be voiced
and to talk about these things.
So a combination of
knowing when it is OK to
pause on processing
and knowing when
it is OK to have an established
time for processing.
EMILY MATLACK: Yeah, sometimes
we really need that safe space.
I know that it allows me to not
get so worked up in the moment,
when I'm like, OK, I can
save this for my radar
because I'll have a little
bit of time between now
and then where I'm not so
volatile in the moment.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
DEDEKER WINSTON: Of course.
EMILY MATLACK: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: So a lot
of the traditional,
as much as you can say--
for a couple of decades,
polyamory advice has been
oriented towards couples
who are opening up.
And it makes sense,
given the society
that we're starting from.
And I'm wondering if you see
that changing, and if so,
what impact that's having
on new relationships.
JASE LINDGREN: Yeah, absolutely.
We've definitely been
seeing this change a lot.
When the term polyamory
was first created--
which was around 1992, on some
DVS systems back in the day--
and at that time, it was
being created almost sort
of like growing out of
the swinger community,
which was very much
focused on couples having
this third person in
their relationship,
or maybe a few other people
in their relationship,
but who were less
important relationships.
Whereas today, there's a
number of things happening.
One is just essentially
the next generation
of polyamorous people, where
there are a lot more people who
identify as solo polyamorous,
which is a term for people who
are polyamorous who are
not looking to become part
of that nesting partnership.
They're not looking for someone
to own a house with and really
settle in in that
traditional way.
And there's also
relationship anarchy,
which, as we mentioned, could
be a whole other talk by itself.
And then the other
really interesting thing
is that now, we have people
who are third generation
polyamorous people, who
not only their parents,
but their parents'
parents, we're polyamorous.
They're obviously very
young at this point.
But we're actually
having people who
were raised with this from
the beginning, which is also
very interesting, and definitely
changes the way that people
approach these types
of relationships,
and definitely gets us away from
that traditional model of just
being centered
around one couple.
DEDEKER WINSTON: And I don't
mean to self-promote too much.
But I tried to do that
in my book as well.
A decade ago when I first
started it, for me, it
was like, oh, I'm opening up
a monogamous relationship.
And there's all that
unique set of challenges
that comes with that.
But within the past
seven, eight years,
that hasn't been my experience.
In the past seven, eight years,
every relationship I've started
has been open from the
very beginning, which
also has its own unique set of
challenges, and pros, and cons.
And also on our
podcast, we really
try to be cognizant
of that as well,
of knowing that it's
not all couple-centric.
Not everybody is in a couple.
Not everyone starts out
monogamous and then opens up.
Because it's true.
Again, contrary to what the
media would have you believe,
there's a lot of
people who start
their relationships this way.
It's not always
the same process.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
DEDEKER WINSTON: Thank you.
EMILY MATLACK: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: So you mentioned
coming out as the top thing
that someone who's
polyamorous could do
to help make a safe community.
I've never tried
to be in a closet.
But when I told my team this
week that, hey, here's a talk
and you should go to it, there
were a large number of them,
some of whom--
most of whom I've worked
with for more than a year--
who didn't know this
about me at all.
How do you be out when
it's not directly related
to your profession?
DEDEKER WINSTON: Well, I
want you to talk about this.
But just to give a
little bit of a preamble,
that's definitely a phenomenon
of what we call mononomativity,
which is similar to
heteronormativity, which
is the assumption that
everyone is heterosexual
and not even questioning that.
And it's kind of
the same thing is
that we have this monomormative
assumption that everyone
is seeking monogamy,
or everyone is
in a monogamous relationship.
So that's the hard thing, is
even if you're not actively
trying to lie, or cover
things up, or be in a closet,
that there's still
this assumption that
often gets placed upon people.
EMILY MATLACK: And may
blow past them, regardless.
it But I want you to share
your experience at work.
JASE LINDGREN: Yeah, so I worked
for a visual effects company
in Los Angeles.
And there's a similar
thing, where I even
have the podcast to be able
to talk about while I'm there.
But there is that
interesting balance of I
don't want to be just throwing
it in everyone's faces
all the time.
But at the same time,
yeah, I would like
to be creating more awareness.
And as someone who is willing
to spend the energy on talking
about this and
answering questions,
I'd like to put myself
out there for that.
And what I found
is it's more just--
as a polyamorous person,
on just a day-to-day level,
it can be really easy to get
into these habits of using
vague language around your
relationships of like, well,
maybe I'll just say girlfriend,
when really what I mean
is partner.
Or really what I mean
is this person I just
started dating that you
haven't heard about before,
but you've already heard me
call someone else girlfriend.
And if I just say
girlfriend, you're
not going to ask me questions,
and I can tell my story
and not have to stop it to
answer all your questions.
But it's essentially trying
to pick the moments when
you do have the
time and the energy
to have those conversations,
and to just work it
into your story in the
same way that if I have
a male partner, rather than
trying to avoid that fact,
I would just say,
oh, my boyfriend.
Or even just saying my partner
will make people go, what?
What do you mean by partner?
Because we have that
association with it.
It's just like
finding little ways
to put that in the conversation,
or something like, oh, I'm
going on a first date tonight.
I'm excited about it--
when you're having
that like, what
are you doing this
weekend conversation.
It's finding those
little ways to be
just a little more conscious
about that mononormative
assumption that everyone's
going to be coming at it with,
to just make that little
mention to make it clear what
your relationships are like.
That's something I found for me.
But I agree.
I've definitely
found that especially
as new people get hired, that
conversation will come up.
And maybe someone
else will mention it.
And then the new person
is like, wait, what?
EMILY MATLACK: Whoa.
JASE LINDGREN: So yeah,
it is something that's
kind of an ongoing process.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
JASE LINDGREN: Thank you.
EMILY MATLACK: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: I have one just
for the sake of clarity.
Could you clearly
define the difference
between polyamory and polygamy?
DEDEKER WINSTON:
Yes, yeah, 100%.
EMILY MATLACK: Absolutely.
DEDEKER WINSTON: And
it just goes-- really,
it's quite simple.
It goes down to just
the roots of the word.
So poly meaning many,
amory meaning love.
Polygamy-- so gamy
refers to spouse.
So specifically, it
means many spouses.
It's not gender specific.
We have a term polygyny,
which is having
multiple female partners.
Or polyandry, which is
multiple male partners.
But culturally, when people
use the word polygamy,
the image that comes to
mind is bearded men named
Ezekiel with child brides.
That's what we think of
when we think polygamy.
And so even though polygamy
just means multiple spouses,
we usually try to
discourage people
from using polyamory and
polygamy interchangeably,
just because of the fact that
polygamy carries this really
charged image along with it.
JASE LINDGREN: A very sexist--
DEDEKER WINSTON: And a very
sexist, unhealthy image.
EMILY MATLACK:
Polyamory, you don't
have to be married, whereas
the assumption is, in what,
polygamy, that
people are married,
but there are multiple wives.
JASE LINDGREN: Thank you.
That's a great
clarifying question.
DEDEKER WINSTON: Really quick--
just the fact that
we, over the course
of running the podcast, over
the course of myself doing
the work that I
do, I have worked
with people who
are monogamous, who
are swingers, who
are polyamorists, who
are relationship anarchists.
And I think when we
started the podcast,
we thought, well, this is
going to be a special advice
podcast with special
advice for people
in non-monogamous relationships.
And now four years
later, we're finding
it's a lot of the same
advice for every single type
of relationship that you
need vulnerable honest
communication, that you need
to choose to trust your partner
rather than fear your
partner, or that you
need to take care of
yourself, that you
need to have boundaries--
that applies across the board.
And so what that says
to me is that either--
regardless of our
relationship choices-- either
we're more similar
than we are different,
or we're just really not
that creative as a podcast.
[LAUGHTER]
EMILY MATLACK:
That's probably it.
If you want to find out
about us a little bit more,
we are at Multiamory.com.
You can find us on
Twitter, @Multiamory.
If you have other
questions, you can email us
at info@multiamory.com.
Also find our podcasts
basically wherever fine podcasts
are sold--
Stitcher, iHeartRadio,
iTunes, et cetera.
JASE LINDGREN: Also Google Play.
EMILY MATLACK: Yes,
oh, Google Play.
Google Play.
DEDEKER WINSTON: We have
a very old Google+ page.
I'm sorry about that.
EMILY MATLACK: Don't look at it.
Please don't.
But also, Dedeker Winston
wrote the amazing book
"The Smart Girl's Guide to
Polyamory," which is for sale.
And also, she will autograph
a copy if you want one today.
Yes.
So with that, thank you.
DEDEKER WINSTON: Thank you.
JASE LINDGREN: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]